fresh soy flour goes in at the top and
comes out packaged at the bottom
economists Avantika is visiting this
food factory outside the Cameroonian
capital yaoundé she says locally
manufactured products like these are
rare and should become more competitive
if you visit so many parts of cameroon
today you realize that most of our food
producing industries have been killed
because of food products coming from the
EU at a local supermarket Cameroonian
products are on the very bottom shelf
almost everything else comes from Europe
takong believes the upcoming trade
agreement will give you products even
more of an edge Cameroon is planning to
scrap import taxes on EU products in
August megu-chan Loeb more is a chicken
farmer and she's afraid of what's to
come
twelve years ago she nearly had to shut
down her business at the time frozen
chicken imports from the EU flooded the
country the meat was so cheap that local
farmers simply couldn't compete takong
and her organization a CD I see have
been supporting farmers like blog more
in the past the protests were successful
in halting imports now log mo faces the
same battle again let's go knock on
yourself we've seen this already and
once the frozen chicken into the market
the small farmers will suffer again
wrongful freedom back in yaoundé Yvonne
Hawking has organized a stakeholders
meeting where reporters and economists
to meet representatives of cameroon's
government and the EU
you know therefore my song concerts we
welcome information meetings like these
where people can voice their concerns
and the government can respond and
discuss possible solutions this time EU
representatives have addressed those
concerns that was apparently stemming
the Cameroonian market so this will
never ever happen again because is
excluded from liberalization so a
victory for local chicken farmers but
that doesn't solve the other issues at
hand
if this is not going to be advantageous
to us and if Cameron is not prepared and
in via the countries have not joined
maybe we should put a hold on the on the
implementation of APIs the EU plans to
put millions of euros into local
businesses but experts project the
economic partnership agreements mean
many small and medium enterprises will
not be able to compete with the influx
of European products